[Music]
hey rob my name is evan i'm from iowa if
you had to go back and make a career
switch but it would have to be a career
where you knew you wouldn't be famous
will you be a plumber or something like
that love the podcast see you wow really
good
question and one that i'm glad i haven't
had to contemplate well you know listen
i i
when i was
a young actor and had a tv show that i
was one of the stars of at 15 for two
years and i thought my career was over
i i really was done being an actor
and i was going to be a marine biologist
and that's what i was studying and
that's what i was interested in
um and then i got the outsiders and that
was that so i guess it would have been
um uh you know a marine biologist
um i also was thinking about doing
something in the law because i i love
that kind of stuff i have a facility for
it um and then i decided you know what
i'm just gonna play lawyers as an actor
i don't have to deal with the bar exam
that way
so how about this how about a lawyer
by day
marine biologist by night
who solves crimes
that's my answer